the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
this is the container what happens in
this is by I guess gets produced in here
he goes out the tube through this set of
tubing and into this container to hold
it this is just clamped off and when you
one clamp it you should be able to get
by I guess from her this and light it
this has only been going for a week and
a half or so so it may be producing I
guess if you like lift did you play with
this you feel some suction on there but
I don't know how much I guess this one
produced you I've been keeping it
upstairs because upstairs is way warmer
than downstairs Cindy loves so yeah when
we're done with ours we're gonna put
them upstairs as well the bases look
something like this
so the first thing we have to do is
measure out 12 inches by 7 inches from
here and
each of your groups if there he's gonna
have to cut one of these out so let's
start by measuring it
I'm gonna run up and grab
plug up the other foot
you want to measure it to inches okay
only one
basically your only ingredients Vienna
biogas digester is this slurry so for
your container you know like for us
we're gonna fill this three corners full
and the ratio of water to human animal
or vegetable or moist is three parts
water to one part and so that is like
one thing that might make basically
that's a factor you'll want to consider
like we were thinking of putting in a
biogas register and where I was in
Tanzania but they their water supply
dries up a few months a year which meant
that just to get water for their family
they would have to either pay more or
walk a really far distance so something
like this would be a lower priority and
there's a good chance that it would dry
up and stop working and after that it's
really hard to get it going again so the
three things that are really important
for a bagger system are a good supply of
the manure having a hot enough
temperature and having a good supply of
water to give those three things it's a
really good solution but if one is
missing
tricky so some wanna dig in
are we doing more than one
Cole the hot water lukewarm
they're gonna know a little more no we
only want their owners
I really need another piece like that
right that goes this listed surprisingly
well yeah pretty rest of us
yeah so so I think this is where the big
the other tubing or the clear tubing
it's supposed to go
yeah make sure this is sealed first for
whatever okay
so one thing that you can do with the
heat sealer is make a soda spec so this
is used for solar disinfection of water
so it's one way that you can purify
water what you do is you can fill any
basically clear plastic container with
water and then you leave it out in the
Sun for about six hours or so and it
will kill the bacteria that's in it so
you might still need to filter it if
it's stupid but as one step that's
actually pretty effective so actually a
d-lab alum MIT alum called Sean frame
his company is called haddock and they
produce these so like an alternative
would be to just fill maybe a plastic
water bottle or this is one but it's not
it uses more material than this would be
more expensive and it's not super easy
to fill like if you're pouring water
from something
so what he came up with
just this back basically you can build
the water yeah so there's a smaller back
here that has a hole in it we actually
in the last session spent a while like
figuring out exactly how the different
parts work because it's a pretty clever
design um and then so basically fold it
down and then the water and then after
your six hours you can just
throwdown
so it's a pretty clever design and this
is something that you can make in the
field to like every time I think Amy
brings a concealer on most of our trips
because there are just a lot of useful
things that you can make
on the I worked on flooring dispensers
for Mikey lab design project and we did
something kind of like this where it's
like this but it's just a one-way valve
so the idea is that you'll be able to
get it out afterwards but this is a
really low cost way for us to like store
the chlorine and then keep people from
getting it out because we didn't want
anyone to be able to siphon it out or
tamper or anything like that
another thing
so this is a drip irrigation kit and the
way this works is you would fill it up
with water and then there a lot of you
have a tube coming out and from that
tube are many little straws and you can
direct a small amount of water straight
to your crops so it's a much more
effective way of irrigating and it uses
a lot less water and someone who I
worked with intense man named Bernard he
has actually made his own like this and
he so he can make the tubes that would
come out of this just from the heat
sealer and locally available plastic
rather than having to buy that or import
it another thing you can do to seal
something like this if you have male and
female pieces like this
you can take some sort of rubber and
make a washer and what you do is have a
rubber washer layer than a plastic or
metal washer and then you can have your
plastic bag like basically the this
piece is a way to and then on the other
side you have another rubber washer
plastic water and then
you can have a seal just as an example
of something else you can do like a way
to connect a bag like this to something
else so the things we have that you can
try out so this machine and this one
worked the same way it's cool to the
touch but basically when you push it
down you'll see a light go on and it
makes it quick
just melts the plastic and there's a you
can vary the heat level here so in some
cases like for the sodas bag like this
you might have some seals where you want
it to go through like two bags but not
three so you can adjust the level so
that it will only melt
so you can tell what kind of edge is
this like thing yeah yeah and so when I
do this then essentially what happens is
is that I prevent water coming in from
here because you know when water hits
here this part is stuck there and so the
other side of this tube is one side of
house my back the other side of this
yeah yes this closings in the back